Star Wars is obsessed with destiny and
with episode 9 completing the sequel
trilogy Rey and kylo ren's stories come
to a dramatic close with huge reveals
about Rey's parents her connection to
the dark side and kylos fate
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jon and
in this video I'll be explaining rey and
kylo ren's journey in the rise of
skywalker and revealing all the hidden
clues that foretold their ultimate
destiny there will of course be spoilers
so take care if you haven't seen the
movie yet in the very final scene of
episode 9 we see rey visit luke's old
home the Lars homestead on Tatooine
where she buries both Luke and Leia
sabers in honor of their sacrifice for
the freedom of the galaxy she then
unveils her own new lightsaber and when
an old lady asks who she is
Rey replies that she's Rey Skywalker as
the force ghosts of Luke and Leia look
upon her it's a bold statement that will
doubtless spark debate because ray isn't
a Skywalker by blood
what Rey's really doing here is twofold
firstly on a personal note she's showing
her allegiance and adopting the family
she identifies with over her biological
one Rey isn't a Jedi because of her
heritage but because of how she chooses
to act and who she chooses to be and
secondly she's taking the legendary
family name and establishing it as an
identity or title for the future Jedi
and Rey looking out over Tatooine with
the twin sons and the distance is of
course a nostalgic callback to a new
hope when Luke looked out over the
sunset and dreamed of adventure and
signals Rey as the new hope for future
generations
in fact Rey becoming an honorary or
adoptive Skywalker is something that the
new trilogy set up early on in the force
awakens at maz kanata's castle ray hears
voices from the basement that lead her
to Luke's old lightsaber that he lost
during his jewel with Darth Vader that
lightsaber was Luke's and his father's
before him and now he calls to you this
is a saber that Rey uses through the
whole of the trilogy Anna's Maz
mentioned it also originally belonged to
Anakin Skywalker later in the force
awakens when Rey and kylo Ren battle for
control of the lightsaber it flies to
raise hand not kylos even though he is a
Skywalker via his mother layers blur
line and kylo felt entitled that
Skywalker savor because of his heritage
blood work super it belongs to me he
eventually gets to wield it in the rise
of Skywalker when Rey passes it to him
through their force bond after he
arrives on X a goal at that point he's
given up the identity of kylo Ren having
turned to the light and become Ben again
making him worthy of wielding the saber
Rey ultimately defeats the Emperor by
combining that legendary lightsaber with
Leia saber which symbolizes the passing
of the baton from both the Skywalker
siblings as well as Ray's vital
connection with them and their crucial
impact on her character and journey in
this saga the way Rey crosses the sabers
together in this scene is a moment that
visually recalls how Luke and Darth
Vader cross lightsabers as they dueled
in front of the Emperor in Return of the
Jedi and that defensive lightsaber
technique which deflects Palpatine's
lightning back to him
reminds me of what Yoda once taught Luke
a Jedi uses the force from the legend
defense never attack Rey embracing the
Skywalker legacy as a title that future
Jedi can use and honor also gives
meaning to the title of episode 9 the
rise of Skywalker and it's something
that Snoke foresaw in the force awakens
if Skywalker returns the New Jedi will
rise and by the way there's also
presidents in the history of our own
galaxy of famous family names becoming
titles at future leaders acquire the
title of Caesar that numerous Roman
emperors gave themselves was taken from
the most famous man of that name Julius
Caesar even though they weren't related
to him by blood the traditional phrase
the king is dead long live the king is
another example of this idea of
continuity with change and the idea that
the Skywalker name will now live on
through future generations of Jedi
please pass down all we know the
thousand generations live in you know
but this is your friend will always be
with you and that Jedi legacy is what
Rey felt when the voices of Jedi past
called to her giving her the strength to
finally defeat Palpatine first what
about Rey's actual bloodline after all
in the force awakens Rey's ancestry and
background were set up as an important
detail to pay
tenshun - where do you come from
classified really me - big secret the
last Jedi
intriguingly subverted many fans
expectations when we discovered her
parents were nobodies do you want to
know the truth about your parents and
her filthy junk traitors
so do you offer drinking money but
similar to obi-wan Kenobi's certain
point of view explanation of his
original claim that Darth Vader killed
Luke's father in episode 9 kylo tells
Rey that her parents chose to be
nobodies to protect her as her father
was Palpatine son making her a
descendent of the Emperor his
granddaughter raised link to the
darkside was strongly hinted out during
her training with Luke in Episode 8 when
she discovered she had a powerful
connection with the dark force beneath
the island he went straight to the dark
that was trying to show me something it
offered something you needed you didn't
even try to stop yourself
Luke was terrified of this given his
previous experience with his nephew I've
seen this raw strength only once before
in den solo it didn't scare me enough
then it doesn't a whole episode 9
further develops this theme of Darkseid
Rey when she gives in to anger and
accidentally lets loose a lightning
blast that blows up a transport ship
thereby revealing her connection to the
Emperor lightning blaster of course
Palpatine signature attack style and Rey
even acknowledges that the Lightning
power came from within her you witness
Ray's struggle to contain her anger and
her path towards the dark side in
episode 9 when she arrives on the wreck
of the second Death Star and enters the
old destroyed throne room of the Emperor
after she picks up the Sith wayfinder
she has a vision an encounter with the
dark version of herself whose seemingly
best sir
the moment has some parallels with
Luke's dark side Cave encounter on
Dagobah when he struck down in anger a
vision of Darth Vader only to reveal his
own face underneath the helmet and when
kylo confronts her on the Death Star and
destroys the wayfinder Rey gives in to
anger again and attacks him in this
jewel Rey's anger fuels her dark side in
a similar way to how Luke became enraged
when he confronted Vader again in Return
of the Jedi
you know he has made your paratha and
just as Luke chopped off Vader's hand
Rey attacks kylo with his own red
lightsaber and stabs him while he's
distracted by a force call from Leia
it's a crucial moment for Rey who's
brought back from the brink of giving in
entirely to the dark side when she
senses layers passing and it makes me
think of how Luke also pulled himself
back from the darkside when the emperor
tried to goad him into killing his
father Darth Vader after race failure to
control her fear and anger she goes to
the island to withdraw herself in the
world as Luke did here she's reunited
with Luke's force ghost who gives her
that crucial third lesson she seems to
have missed in the last Jedi Luke
reminds her that retreating from the
world of fear isn't the answer
confronting fear is the destiny of the
Jedi
your destiny after all as Yoda
previously told Luke Angel
pre-compression the dark Saturday and
Leia told ray at the beginning of
episode 9 to never be afraid of who she
is Leia already knew that Ray was a
Palpatine but as Luke explains his
sister understood that race spirit and
heart were more important and that some
things are stronger than blood and this
is perhaps one of the biggest messages
to take away from these films that no
one is or should be completely defined
by their past
after all poe is a former spice runner
Finn and Jana were both stormtroopers
and Rey was a scavenger but more
important than their previous lives all
the families they were born into or even
forced into is the family they later
choose for themselves or adopt as their
own just as Maz Kanata told right in the
force awakens
the belonging you seek is not behind you
it is ahead and Maz followed utter by
asking her to take Luke's lightsaber a
sign that raised true family and sense
of connection would be with the
Skywalker's and the Jedi by the end of
episode 9 Rey understands this and
rejects Palpatine when he tells her that
the throne is her birthright and instead
allies herself who then to stand against
the Emperor and the sis understand kylo
ren's redemptive arc we need to go back
to the beginning of the force awakens
where we find him already conflicted in
his feelings of allegiance to the dark
side
forgive me I feel it again the call to
the light supreme leader senses it in
fact there's an intriguing message
underlying what races to kylo after he
captures her in the force awakens you're
afraid that you will never be as strong
as Darth Vader the hidden meaning in
this line is that although Vader was a
villain he eventually found the strength
to turn back to the light side and stand
against the Emperor
kylo however believed he needs to be
strong to embrace the dark side which we
see in what he says to his father Han
Solo just before killing him no no what
I have to do but I don't know if I have
the strength to do it
but in Episode nine kylo eventually
finds true strength when he talks to his
father again after his battle with Rey
on the Death Star
han who appears as one of his memories
reminds him that Ben isn't dead but kylo
Ren is and using the same words that he
said to his father on Starkiller base
then now throws his lightsaber into the
water finally rejecting his darkside
identity of kylo Ren that eventual
redemption for him began in the last
Jedi where Rey felt that the connection
she was beginning to establish through
their force bond meant he could still be
turned back to the light side you failed
him by thinking his choice was made it
wasn't there's still conflict in him
just now when we touched Hanson I saw
his future if I go to him then solo will
turn then he's our last hope and Ben
does become Rey's lost hope when he
stands with her against the emperor and
then brings her back by force healing
her after she collapses from the
exertion of killing Palpatine
it was also Carlos connection with his
mother Leia that kept him from fully
turning to the dark side in the last
Jedi he stopped himself from firing upon
layers ship when he sensed her presence
and that moment is revisited in the rise
of Skywalker when Leia coerced to him
and stops him from delivering a fatal
blow to Rey during their jewel on the
Death Star
together both Leia and Han bring their
son back something that Leia told Han
they would do in the force awakens we
can still save him me so basically what
loss and Tucker told kylo at the very
beginning of the sequel trilogy turned
out to be right you cannot deny the
truth that is your family I know where
you come from before you called yourself
kylo Ren ultimately his kylo Ren
alter-ego has been a performance a big
act by a person trying to take on the
enormous mantle of the infamous Darth
Vader
unlike Vader though kylo didn't require
his helmet to survive take off that mask
it was just another way to conceal who
he really was while he tried every way
he could to be something he ultimately
wasn't your no Vader no just a child and
the mask
so although kylo Ren had worshipped the
legend of the Sith Lord Darth Vader by
the end like Anakin Ben rejects the
emperor and the where the Sith and
redeems himself now how do you feel
about Ray and kylos endings in the rise
of Skywalker and their arcs through the
sequel trilogy comment with your
thoughts below and if you enjoyed this a
sons up is hugely appreciated and don't
forget to subscribe to get all my new
videos tapleft for my next Star Wars
video or tap write for another video
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers